jerilee it's lovely to see you here at
learning film on comic can't we can't
believe it keeps getting bigger and
bigger doesn't it just lovely to see so
many people so eager friday night the
rush hour traffic and i only live 15
minutes away but it's really good to see
so many people what are you going to
enjoy most about this weekend you think
well what i will be doing and I've told
a lot of people a lot of people know
I'll be dressing up in the in the
costume it's a replica but i'll try and
make it as nasty and well Boba Fett is
Boba Fett so we'll see what happens I
mean I'm Bob of it sorry k to me that
happens I'm sorry right you're going
wrong speaking of Boba Fett I mean
course everyone loves him and we want to
see him come back in some way or another
now there has been various directors
who've been attached to various Star
Wars spin-offs recently brilliant
british director cause gareth edwards
who did the recent godzilla movie what
do you think about that fantastic yes I
mean people keep asking me are you going
to be mobile fit again I said I don't
know what I did before I enjoyed very
much but if I was to show my face I'm
you know beginning to get on me now you
can get away with a certain about but
whatever happens I will look forward to
seeing the film because it's there is
ready to go and is the dark side there's
all sorts of things going on so I'm
that's me I'm looking forward to see
what they do with a spin-off this kind
of talk around various characters that
people are kind of putting out there
that there might be a good time spin us
of all the spin us might be about and
one of them is Bob affair now what would
you like to see Boba Fett do if he came
back for one of these spin-offs Boba
Fett should be as cool as he was right
at the beginning and he doesn't move
very much so a little look with their
helmet on is dangerous so you don't know
what he's going to do but there's going
to be I think there's going to be an
awful lot going on with him but at the
moment we haven't heard apart from
episode 7 that's underway we'll probably
have to wait a tree while for episode 8
otherwise I'll destroy every party if
you could have any other characters
return evil spin-off you would you like
to return probably Han Solo mainly
because I think Boba Fett enhance hello
they they fought together they were
probably in the Millennium Falcon had a
row and said you do that it all that you
know that business and they they
separate they were friends rather like
the wookie is friends with han Solo I
believe Boba Fett were good both good
pilots and they could fly in the
Millennium that's that that would be the
character of course he mentioned episode
7 which everyone was kind of going crazy
about cuz it's been talking about
filming in the forest of dean at the
moment everyone's trying to get a
look-in what's going on what do you
think about it having being filmed in
the UK for so well but i think was most
important because i remember fighting
and fighting they're working all that
time ago elstree it's just great that
they're using
missions from England the cameraman
there's a good mixture I can't wait to
see why I really care and people say oh
come on you've done you've been in the
films what do you mean you're waiting no
I can't I'm very excited like I like my
grandchildren although they like any
part of it so I've stopped that and but
they get very excited about something I
go whoo it's rather like the Doctor Who
when you dive behind the sofa and go oh
it's scary but nothing is as scary as
both effect I mean what is done here cuz
I shouldn't be here because I'll be
destroying people and what are you most
looking forward to seeing about Star
Wars when it comes out next year I want
to see people the peaceful way that
people go around chatting to be brass if
they're queuing up to see the new film
episode 7 music coming out of the cinema
this is episode 7 maybe they could get
me to do the funny voice of it at the
end or the beginning so that that will
be really geeing it up people people are
really longing to see this next film
episode 7 so get down to your local
cinema there'll be bags and fish and
chips for you to watch this with a glass
of wine so please follow me because I
finally what are the chances that we
will see you back as Bob affairs I don't
know there are chances and they're not
chances sometimes you're lucky sometimes
you're not if it doesn't happen it will
be fun to do something or just maybe a
cameo just leaning against a bomb
because if he's a bad guy you can't
smoke but you could lean there with
a light ale or something or gin and
tonic looking menacing yeah just looking
menacing and the odd turn of the head so
maybe you know you never know but if I'm
not it's still I was still and I'll pay
our paid to see the film I'm waiting to
see the results it's going to be going
to be doing Jerry as always it's an
absolute pleasure sweetie thanks so much
today thank you very much
you